hola bienvenidos a este especial en el
que vamos a analizar qué le sucedió a la
economía mundial en 2021 soy daniela
blandón y me acompaña en estudio jorge
hurtado quien también hace parte del
equipo económico de france en 24 jorge
buenas buenas que tal pues comenzamos
por decir que las economías ya se están
recuperando del duro golpe sufrido el
año anterior por culpa de la pandemia
pero eso no quiere decir que las
actividades productivas hayan vuelto a
lo que eran antes sino que su base de
comparación es el año anterior jorge por
qué no damos un repaso por el mundo así
que tenían la y bueno me gustaría
iniciar desde contándote desde la
recesión de 2008 y 2009 el producto
interno bruto mundial no se contraía
aunque sí se estaba desacelerando en
2020 cayó un 3,1 por ciento siendo las
economías avanzadas las más perjudicadas
pero qué hechos marcaron este
comportamiento se lo preguntamos a
daniel lacalle él es economista el
profesor y gestor de inversiones y esto
nos dijo
pues cuando se reabre la economía las
cifras de aparente crecimiento pues
aparecen como muy espectaculares pero en
realidad rebotar es decir cuando la
economía cae mucho en un año por el
cierre forzoso y en el momento en el que
se reabre esa economía pues vuelve a ver
está vuelve a ver producto no industrial
el consumo se recupera pero hablamos de
eso exactamente de rebotar vuelta no de
crecer completamente distinto
y por supuesto los gobiernos están
intentando dar una imagen
muy optimista de la recuperación y están
utilizando el concepto de crecimiento
para una cosa que en la inmensa mayoría
de las familias de los agentes
económicos no es más que recuperar parte
de lo perdido durante la parte mía tanto
hay mucho de propaganda
e intentar insuflar a mí mismo pero
claramente y sobre todo en muchos países
de latinoamérica
esos porcentajes de rebote dejan todavía
a la mía muy lejos de donde estaba en el
cuarto trimestre de 2009
bastante razón tenía nuestro invitado
ahora veamos américa latina según la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe la cepal la región crecerá un
5 9% en 2021 y es que en 2020 la
situación había sido peor que en el
resto del mundo con una caída del 7%
venezuela panamá y perú fueron los que
más cayeron pero jorge que podrá
esperarse este año bueno daniela para
2021 las proyecciones son menos sombrías
en los gráficos se muestra que los
países que más sufrieron son los que más
se están recuperando panamá perú y chile
podrían ver aumentos entre el 9 y el 12
por ciento pero qué países saldrán más
rápido de la recesión y cuáles no nos lo
explica nuestro analista invitado
y si miramos latinoamérica básicamente
hay una serie de países que van a salir
mucho más debilitados de la pandemia
serían fundamentalmente argentina brasil
méxico que ya está dando la datos
digamos estancamiento etcétera y países
como chile colombia costa rica
están tantos datos y son más positivos
porque además al contrario que por
ejemplo venezuela brasil o argentina no
tienen esos niveles de inflación
cambiamos de tema y vamos a mencionar
uno que dio y que sigue dando de qué
hablar que es la crisis de suministros
naciones unidas estima que si se
mantiene el aumento en el costo de los
fletes de contenedores los precios de
las importaciones mundiales se elevarían
en 11% y el valor final al consumidor en
1,5 por ciento de aquí a 2023 desde la
industria automotriz pasando por
productores de papel higiénico
segmento hasta fabricantes de juguetes
navideños podría decirse que muy pocos
se escapan a la aguda crisis originada
en la pandemia pero a eso se suman otros
factores sobre cuáles así es bueno y es
que el comercio electrónico se ha
multiplicado a niveles que no existían
antes incluso esa demanda de productos
ha superado significativamente la
capacidad del mercado para producir o
enviar lo que se pide hay quienes ya ni
siquiera van el supermercado a la
ferretería oa restaurantes porque hacen
todos sus pedidos en línea de ahí que
haya surgido pues varias crisis de
niebla y ahora pues hay que decir
también que eso finalmente se traduce en
aumentos de precios porque no vemos el
siguiente informe
este aviso en una panadería de parís es
una especie de consuelo para sus
clientes
advierte que sus productos suben de
precio - el panda jets
con los molineros acordamos que a partir
del primero de noviembre nos iban a
subir el precio de la harina aquí hemos
decidido no aumentar el precio del
paquete para no impactar a nuestros
clientes pero si incrementaremos todos
los precios de nuestros panes especiales
y dada
la razón el trigo ha subido 30 por
ciento a nivel mundial desde septiembre
la energía ha alcanzado cotizaciones
históricas por cuenta de los elevados
precios del gas y la crisis de
contenedores retrasa la entrega de
productos básicos que el largo y
crujiente alimento básico aumente su
valor entre 3 y 5 céntimos por unidad
desde un promedio de 89 céntimos aunque
parezca poco si hace la diferencia
de que la barra de pan baguette se ha
incrementado en 23 céntimos en los
últimos 20 años esto demuestra la
proximidad con este producto porque él
es muy preciado tanto para los panaderos
como para los franceses el 70% de los
ballets se venden en panaderías
el baguette es considerado por muchos
uno de los mejores barómetros de la
atmósfera económica en francia por eso
de que se resuelvan todos los cuellos de
botella nacidos en la pandemia depende
que la economía francesa retomen la
senda de crecimiento y que los 67
millones de consumidores voraces en este
país puedan seguir masticando un
promedio estimado de 320 y baguettes por
segundo
y el valle de en francia y muchos
productos también en américa latina'
jorge y en todo el mundo pero así como
ha habido muchos perdedores con esta
pandemia por qué no hablar de los
ganadores por ejemplo quienes reciben
remesas el banco mundial estima que los
flujos de transferencias hacia los
países de renta baja y media alcanzaron
los 589 mil millones de dólares en 2021
es decir 73 por ciento más frente a 2020
pero en américa latina y el caribe el
flujo es aún mayor y pudo subir más del
21 por ciento jorge bueno las remesas
habrían alcanzado
probablemente un nuevo máximo de 126 mil
millones de dólares en 2021 siendo
méxico el que se lleva una mayor tajada
del botín regional en 2021 los cinco
principales receptores de remesas en
dólares estadounidenses fueron india
china méxico filipinas y egipto
jorge y un fenómeno también que para
muchos es extraño es que a la economía
le ha ido mal mientras que el mercado
bursátil pasa por su mejor momento
un caso característico es el de la bolsa
de buenos aires en argentina su
principal índice creció casi un 60% solo
en 2021 a pesar de que la economía de
este país no andan nada bien como se
explica el caso de argentina consultamos
con andrés moreno quien es asesor
financiero y analista económico y
bursátil pero realmente hay que entender
la anticipación que hay de algunos
inversionistas comprando activos baratos
también hay que entender que en algún
momento la inflación va a generar que la
gente para que se proteja de ello tenga
que ir a comprar acciones cuando hay un
ambiente inflación las acciones son un
buen refugio por las acciones también
empiezan a subir las empresas empiezan
también a reflejar eso en los precios
también hay que entender que no como son
países latinoamericanos que essalud sus
valorados y que no tuvieron ese rally
internacional esa subida de precios pues
es normal que llegue alguna oportunidad
a pesar del entorno que hay lo que
tienen que saber los inversionistas es
que hay mucha incertidumbre y va a haber
mucha volatilidad esto en américa latina
pero que decir de wall street bueno
daniela hasta el 30 de noviembre de 2021
los tres principales índices de la bolsa
de nueva york- acumularon ganancias del
14 por ciento en el caso del down game y
un 23% aproximado en sus otros dos
índices principales el estándar en pur y
el nasdaq y en europa la situación fue
bastante similar le preguntamos al
respecto andrés moreno nuestro invitado
y esto no dijo
bueno en este momento de recuperación
económica y activación mundial las
bolsas no tuvieron un comportamiento
igual en todo el mundo en los países
líderes del mundo como eeuu como las
bolsas de europa y en algunos casos las
asiáticas llegaron a máximos históricos
están en una entre comillas burbuja en
todo el mundo buscando menor riesgo
economías desarrolladas son países que
también rápidamente obtener obtuvieron
vacunas entonces son índices que están
en máximos históricos por el contrario
los países emergentes los países
latinoamericanos tuvieron alguna recaída
en sus bolsas había la recuperación
económica no es creíble por parte de
algunas agencias calificadoras
adicionalmente hay unos riesgos
políticos y los capitales se están
migrando hacia
refugios más sólidos como el dólar
estadounidense y algunos activos en eeuu
entonces las bolsas latinoamericanas en
estos momentos presentan una gran
oportunidad porque es donde están los
activos más baratos
en todos mercados búrsatiles los
invitamos ahora a repasar algunas de las
noticias económicas del año 2021 en cuba
después de dos décadas dejó de existir
la doble moneda desde el primero de
enero desapareció el peso convertibles
que era el equivalente al dólar y ahora
solo es permitido el peso cubano como
moneda local esto significó para muchos
un dramático aumento en los precios de
la canasta familiar el gobierno de
miguel díaz canel también levantó la
prohibición de crear empresas privadas
que había regido por más de medio ciclo
el primero de octubre entró en vigencia
en venezuela una nueva reconversión
monetaria la tercera desde 2008 el banco
central eliminó seis ceros al bolívar
como una manera de enfrentar la
hiperinflación
el salvador se convirtió en el primer
país del mundo en adoptar el bitcoin
como moneda de curso legal la medida que
entró en vigencia el 7 de septiembre
generó críticas por parte de las
autoridades económicas mundiales y de
ciudadanos que han tenido problemas con
la aplicación de pagos creada por el
gobierno
el 2021 fue un año excepcional para el
retiro anticipado de pensiones en
américa latina' en chile los ciudadanos
completaron su tercer acceso al 10% de
los ahorros en poco más de un año en
bolivia fue autorizado un retiro de
hasta el total de los fondos
previsionales según el caso y el
congreso de perú aprobó una ley similar
mientras que otros países de la región
están contemplando la misma posibilidad
jorge y entre tantas cifras de todo este
año cuál sería para usted la cifra
económica de 2021 bueno daniela sin duda
para mí fueron los 52 mil millones de
dólares que logró en capitalización de
mercado la fintech brasileña no bank el
día que comenzó a cotizar en la bolsa de
nueva york ese 9 de diciembre el banco
digital se convirtió en la tercera
empresa cotizada más valiosa de brasil
ahora muy importante porque además de
ser brasileña también tiene capital
colombiano digamos que es un buen
emprendimiento de la región con esto nos
despedimos a ustedes muchas gracias por
hacer parte de este especial a jorge
también a nuestros invitados y también
les invitamos a que vean nuestra página
web www france24 puntocom ya que
consulten nuestras redes sociales
hola